the special effects were so good and it
was just so fun so fun the night fights
were some of the best choreographed
hand-to-hand acts there was a lot of
like oh my gosh stuff I couldn't and I
really don't know if it was all real so
tonight we went and saw what must have
been one of the first theatrical
showings of Captain America the Winter
Soldier and I think is a consensus it
was amazing it was but I I said when we
finished the movie um I have enjoyed all
of the Marvel films in one way or the
other
but a lot of them in-between have felt
just felt like kind of holdovers to the
Avengers yeah they don't feel like real
movies they feel like there's no the
first Captain America was a very long
post credit sequence yes yes it felt
like that you paid money to see this was
the first Marvel film that I was like
this is a full movie its sequel it moves
everything along it's a sequel obviously
yeah but it's a full movie I will watch
it again I will enjoy it on its own
merits it feels like it takes place in
our world I thought it was fantastic
so I feel like this movie was basically
Mission Impossible starring Captain
America which is still like an awesome
movie but also the Falcon I think was
the most charming person on screen I
think Anthony Mackie you know didn't
squeal when he came on screen that first
ya know he's he's the best Chris Evans
is maturing definitely into the role of
Captain America even a different haircut
I think he's had three different
haircuts now from Falcon is an amazing
addition to the Marvel Universe and or
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and the
flight action scenes are incredibly done
there's a specific moment where Captain
America is falling and he has to catch
him and I've never seen a a kind of
aerial stunt because it's CGI done so
realistic well there was a great aerial
Sun in the third Iron Man you know yes I
just mean it's kind of funny we're
talking about the individual moments
from this and in my opinion this move
I felt like a collection of the best
moments from like 17 different genre
movies like there's spy elements and
they're really well done spy oh yeah and
then there's this one big huge comic
book movie moment that like can't exist
in the real world but can totally exist
in a Captain America movie and it's
amazingly well done they ground it more
than any other Marvel film but they also
have this kind of sensationalist very
comic book feel everything's very
heightened
I mean it's Captain America he's
throwing his shield it's bouncing off of
people's faces landing back his hand
things like that but it also has this it
I hate to use this term because it's
overused but it is a little darker than
the other Marvel films but it's also
still a comic-book fun yeah I mean II DS
not when when we say dark when it
relates to comic book movies all I think
it's sort of unnecessarily gen and this
was all plot driven it's very it is very
violent for for a more fulfillment
yeah the body count is out of control
where does this stack up in all of the
Marvel movies from all the Marvel movies
I still think Iron Man 3 was the best I
think this comes in the next and the
reason I still think Iron Man 3 is the
best is because I had better humor I
think a Robert Downey jr. is a much more
charming actor than Chris Evans I think
if anyone stole the show it was Nick
Fury just the way he liked it's such a
badass in those car chases and Maria
Hill has a lot more to do in this movie
too which is really good Cobie Smulders
really takes over that role it's
interesting to know that the women in
this movie aren't damsels in distress
the same way like Lois Lane and mane of
Steel is just like oh I need help save
me in this movie the women truly kick
ass saying I do want to talk a little
bit about the villains because we were
discussing how they're different in this
movie but yeah I personally I love all
the Marvel movies I've had a big ongoing
problem with their bill in Slate and
frankly I think dating from the first
Iron Man movie every Marvel movie you
know they're gonna get rid of this guy
at the end of the picture and it kind of
makes them throw aways and more than
that they all go insane in the third act
I mean
watch them I guarantee a hundred percent
every Marvel movie the villains go nuts
in the third act and in this movie they
have not won but I think the case could
be made like three or four really bill
and s characters who never betray what
they're about I mean they are perfectly
executed start to finish yeah so Captain
America the Winter Soldier we obviously
were all big fans of it the reviews have
been amazing did was a very big fan I
heard the noises so phase two is turning
out great for the morrow for MCU I mean
it's it's huge yeah Iron Man 3 was great
Thor 2 and we have guardians of the
galaxy later this year which just looks
beyond yeah amazing so comment below let
us know what you thought of Captain
America the Winter Soldier and where it
kind of lands in the Marvel pantheon
until next time I'm Ryan I'm Sam I'm
David thank you for watching